so did you kill anyone
with my own hands
no no I never killed anyone
we were all marching we were on your
side
really
and which side was that
uh
the side of the Vietnamese people
the people in the north of the people in
the South
well all of them I guess
we all look the same after all right
I mean I could be Vietcong for all you
know a spy
how would you know
I'm not of course I love America
[Music]
here in America we welcome people like
you
[Music]
sure you guys are refugees
what if I told you
that I
was a communist
undercover welcome to the world of
spycraft
we sent you to America so you could be
our mode
let's do a mall when it is suddenly
thrust into the sun this is
counterintelligence it gets wet down
here
what are you concealing I don't know if
I can go on like this
hmm
oh how about this you work for me I'm
pretending to work for them your spy on
the counters by at the same time your
spine right
look at you all serious man you'd be a
terrible spy